100 días de Lula tres meses después de
la investidura de Luis Ignacio lulada
Silva como presidente de Brasil superior
ha comenzado a dividir las opiniones de
la sociedad brasileña el mandatario de
izquierda ha enfocado sus esfuerzos en
impulsar programas sociales reabrir
fondos para el medio ambiente y en las
poblaciones indígenas así como
reestructurar el esquema político y
militar que dejó Yahir bolsonaro sin
embargo algunos brasileños creen que
Lula ya no es el mismo que gobernó en 23
y en 2011 Aunque otros aún creen en el
proyecto del presidente
no estoy viendo mucho solo lo veo a él
hablando más de problemas del gobierno
anterior Pero él mismo no está haciendo
mucho las empresas están cerrando y
algunas cosas en la economía no están
avanzando
yo creo que su gobierno es bueno no lo
considero malo a la gente le gusta cosas
que él está haciendo hay otros a los que
no les gusta también pero todo el mundo
tiene su opinión entre mi familia y mis
conocidos a muchos no les gusta pero yo
lo felicito
de igual manera Lula ha tenido el
objetivo de que Brasil regrese al
escenario internacional después de la
política aislacionista de bolsonaro ha
reabierto el banco de desarrollo
brasileño para proyectos en la región y
ha sido sumamente activo en la
cooperación internacional para la
protección del Amazonas Lula llega a la
primera meta de su mandato con un
proyecto que muchos advierten se ha
quedado corto para las expectativas